want to talk about Jeff Sessions briefly
last week in his bizarre and pretty
obviously dishonest testimony Trump
Attorney General Jeff Sessions said in
more ways than one I didn't do anything
wrong he couldn't remember a lot of key
things but he didn't meet with Russian
agents he didn't meet with officials he
didn't meet with representatives he
didn't discuss anything he didn't do
anything he's completely innocent of
anything you might have at any point
considered thinking that he might have
maybe done unfortunately a lobbyist
whose job it is to lobby for Russian
interests and also a lobbyist who wrote
Trump's big foreign policy speech during
his campaign said hey you know what I
attended two dinners that were hosted by
Jeff Sessions during the election this
is the lobbyist Richard Burt who told
The Guardian I did attend two dinners
with groups of former Republican foreign
policy officials and Senator sessions
recall this bit of testimony take a
listen to this during the 2016 campaign
season do you have any contacts with any
representative including any American
lobbyists or agent of any Russian
company within or outside your capacity
as a member of Congress remember the
Armed Services Committee I don't believe
so
yeah very specific question even asked
by John McCain they're about American
lobbyists working for Russia and Jeff
sessions that I don't believe so the
fact that Bert is a lobbyist on behalf
of Russia is pretty well known in
Washington it's a matter of public
record a better defense of the meeting
would be well listen this guy was
writing Trump speeches so it makes sense
that a campaign surrogate like sessions
would meet with him setting aside the
fact that Bert someone acting on behalf
of the Russian government is helping to
trade shaped Trump's foreign policy
positions which is concerning in and of
itself but the point is once again
sessions was not telling the truth he
had met with a lobbyist a lobbyist for
Russia McCain specifically asked did you
meet with any lobbyists for Russia and
Bert has a long history of this none of
this is surprising or secret
and that's why these lawyerly type
answers help them out because sessions
didn't say no he said I don't believe so
right and your belief is completely
different from what the evidence on the
ground is you can believe whatever you
want
now the other connection with Burt is
that Burt wrote major parts of Donald
Trump's foreign policy speech this
speech was given at the Mayflower Hotel
at this infamous meeting now infamous
event attended by Russian ambassador
Sergei Kiss lyac was it which is a part
of a totally different Jeff Sessions
controversy recession set that said
something like I possibly met with kids
react and defenders are pointing to the
denials about the kiss lyac meetings
from last week's testimony saying well
hold on listen he said that a meeting is
not the same as shaking someone's hand
in a big room of people or whatever why
on earth should we believe anything that
Jeff Sessions said about the kiss lyac
meetings if he is either lying or can't
remember his meetings with a known
lobbyist for Russian interests yeah I
know next to nothing about Richard Burt
but I'm more willing to believe his
story because we know that Jeff's
session lies even when he's under oath
it's one of those things about a known
known versus an unknown known I know
that sessions is going to lie even in
that position it's like the Comey Trump
thing right are we going to believe
Comey who took notes immediately and
although we could say he made political
mistakes in his career he is not a known
liar or are we going to believe Trump
who at this point is scrambling to avoid
potentially everything up to a you know
an impeachment conviction and this is
where we get into the whole thing of I
don't recall not within my recollection
and where it becomes key McCain asked
sessions did you meet with this lobbyist
and as Pat pointed out sessions said I
don't believe so
sessions definitely met with the
lobbyists is he truly the most forgetful
man in Washington is he lying and can it
be demonstrated in courts that is a very
very difficult thing to to prove
definitively that someone remembered how
do you prove someone remembered
something and it seems that he's using
these non definitive disavows to
maintain possible deniability about oh I
didn't remember it at the time I don't
see how it could be done I mean you can
jog someone's memory that's entirely
possible to forget and then re remember
the Guardian asked Carter page for
comment about all this and Carter page
said quote in the grand scheme of head
of things
the severe civil rights abuses by
Clinton Obama Comey regime carried out
against myself and other supporters of
the Trump campaign in their illegal
attempts to influence the 2016 election
will help clarify how irrelevant all
these petty side questions are basically
Carter page saying look at Hillary and
Obama instead and the last major aspect
of this because and this is not getting
a lot of attention because of how crazy
the Russia collusion stuff is getting an
American lobbyist for Russian interests
helped craft Donald Trump's important
foreign policy speech we have lobbyist
sponsored foreign policy in the United
States lobbyists working for non
friendly foreign powers are writing what
the president then presidential
candidate says about Russian relations
that should make everybody who cares
about the Constitution American
sovereignty that should make everybody
very very concerned and that is not
getting a lot of attention because there
is again scandal after scandal after
scandal hopefully it'll get more
attention we are on reddit at david
pakman.com slash re d di t discuss this
story or any others you like on our
discussion forum today's program is made
possible in part by Gamefly which is
sort of like netflix for video games
they've got over 8,000 new and classic
games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 Wii
and a bunch of other platforms and you
can also stream games you don't even
need a gaming console or a computer
because you can stream games through
your Amazon fire stick or Roku box and
then use your mobile phone as the
controller you can play as many games as
you want for one monthly fee and if you
find some games you want to keep you can
buy them for a low used price never with
due dates or late fees and our audience
can get a 30-day free trial and Gamefly
offer.com /t dps the games are shipped
directly to you with return envelopes
included no contracts and you can also
stream the games I think I mentioned
that you can also rent games through the
mobile app get a free 30-day trial for
david pakman show viewers and listeners
and support our show at Gamefly
offer.com /t DPS